bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors un article 24
réécrit et remplacé je le disais un
instant remplacé par le sénat par un
délit de provocation à l'identification
est ce que pour autant il présente
toujours les mêmes risques pour les
libertés
selon les manifestants au la liberté
d'expression en france est mise à mal
depuis la crise qu vide voire même bien
avant pour une raison toute simple c'est
que nous sommes dans une crise sociale
économique depuis des années et que les
pouvoirs qui se succèdent n'ont pas de
solution problème si ce n'est que deux
disciplines la dette et de la répression
donc tant qu'on n'aura pas mis en place
une classe politique capable
qu'elles soient de droite ou de gauche
peu importe capable de redresser la
situation économique est ce notre pays
là mais on aura des lois de plus en plus
liberticides du scotch ou la situation
deviendra irrécupérable est ce que
finalement l'article 24 un peu fait
diversion il a fait oublier tous les
autres articles que comporte ce projet
de loi au delà de ça c'est même toute
cette politique là tu sais tu comment de
la proposition de loi cristallise toutes
les toutes les colères et toutes les
attentes sur le gouvernement qui
aujourd'hui même dans la crise qu vide
est complètement maladroit dans sa
communication et j'ai l'impression que
tout ce qui va proposer aujourd'hui va
cristalliser l'opinion contre lui ça va
être très compliqué sa stratégie est
très simple à comprendre c'est de faire
monter le front national le plus haut
possible pour pouvoir avoir une chance
de gagner
je voudrais aussi en profiter pour
passer un coup de gueule ou non de
beaucoup de chefs d'entreprises parce
que pendant cette crise co-lead la
plupart n'ont pas les aides ont
clairement conformément à ce que disent
le gouvernement et notamment concernant
les aides pour les apprentis puisqu'il
faut attendre entre six et huit mois
d'attentes avant de percevoir les aides
c'est inacceptable alors pour revenir à
cette journée de mobilisation contre le
projet de loi sécurité globale les
mesures de surveillance sont au coeur de
la proposition avec l'extension en des
personnes pouvant accéder aux images de
vidéosurveillance
l'utilisation de drones aussi qu'a dit
la piscine parce qu'il me semble qu'elle
a été saisie
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il ya un
problème on est dans une politique de
plus en plus répressives on va outillés
de plus en plus les forces de l'ordre
qui elles sont des êtres humains qui
souvent sont dépassés face à un laxisme
non pas judiciaire liée aux juges mais
par rapport aux lois qui ont été mises
en place je vous rappelle que lorsque
quelqu'un comme un délit il ne risque
quasiment plus rien dans notre pays donc
on met des lois de plus en plus
contraignantes
on est en train d'attaquer la liberté
d'expression parce que c'est simple à
comprendre notre pays est en train de
connaître une crise économique sociale
majeure depuis pas aujourd'hui mais
depuis quasiment 40 ans et
qu'aujourd'hui les pouvoirs ne savent
plus comment faire pour répondre si ce
n'est que de faire la répression et ce
genre de loi là on va les retrouver de
plus en plus et on va équiper de plus en
plus les forces de l'ordre après envoyé
le bâton dit attention si jamais il ya
des tensions sociales
on tapera dessus et le problème il va
continuer à croître à croître à croître
jusqu au jour la situation deviendra
incontrôlable
vous le disiez ça va qu'on assiste un
peu un vent de colère ces derniers temps
en france on a eu des grèves massives
dans les transports pour dénoncer
l'assurance retraite le mouvement des
débits des jaunes là les manifestations
des enseignants des soignants fin du
personnel des services publics français
maintenant cette mobilisation contre le
projet doit sécurité globale
qu est il en train de se passer en
france les français sont en colère ça
fait 40 ans que notre pays décline parce
qu'elle est choix politiques économiques
et sociaux qui ont été contre eux
l'intérêt du pays ou qui ont été très
mauvais un petit peu comme pour que les
français comprennent ce qui s'est passé
en 1870 71 en 1939 où on n'avait non
plus une classe politique
une élite mais on avait une caste qui
prenait qui faisait que des mauvais
choix qui nous a mené droit dans le mur
sauf que là on a pas de guerre en face
physique mais économiquement n'a les
mêmes conséquences les français
s'aperçoivent qu'ils s'appauvrissent on
s'appauvrit aujourd'hui on donne un
exemple simple il ya 30 ans avec un smic
on pouvait acheter une maison dans ma
génération
quand j'étais jeune avec un smic on
pouvait louer aujourd'hui avec un smic
on peut à peine être locataire si on est
seul avec un enfant c'est très compliqué
la plupart des gens qui travaillent
réclament les logements sociaux
donc on voit bien qu'un appauvrissement
général du pays il ya des mauvais choix
et que sue qui amènent des mauvais choix
depuis 40 ans sont toujours au pouvoir
et comme ils n'ont pas de solution au
problème
il ne fonctionne que par la répression
et sale histoire est sans appel à chaque
fois qu'un gouvernement quel que soit le
pays a agi comme ça ça c'est toujours
mal terminé la question c'est quand et
comment donc ça l'avenir nous le dira
david poulin vous êtes président du
syndicat et des journées constructif et
conseiller municipal en faire bercy
d'avoir le petit à nos questions